doing Shakespeare for you do you like
the discipline of having to respect the
text because you're sort of known for
improvising around uh scripts aren't you
hard to add Luke Shakespeare
hard to ad-lib Shakespeare so that
that's a part of the challenge I mean
that that's that's a part of the fun of
it no because on Training Day your Oscar
winning performance and Training Day how
much of that did you improvise
uh a lot
a lot I don't know 40 30 I don't know
but but or I added things I shouldn't
say improvise it from beginning to end
a monologue or or whatever but but I was
sort of figuring it it out as I as I
went along and there and put Josh Josh
Whitaker here was it training day you
went to see and had a very disappointing
experience yes I've always wanted to ask
you this actually Denzel
um yes
I want to see Training Day at uh the
cineworld in um just near Stockport in
Manchester view I don't know if you know
it probably not
that's that's neither here nor there um
so um when we got in this there was a
problem with the sound right so there
was no sound for the first 30 minutes
and they were trying to sort the sound
up the pictures were going and then
because they're on a strict time
schedule when the sound came on they
didn't take it back to the start we just
watched the rest of the film
so and that now obviously I'm never you
always want to watch a new film so
you're never going to sit down and watch
the first half hour of a film you've
seen the end of so I've never seen it so
my question is what happens in the first
half hour of Training Day
all right here's what I'll do how much
time do you have
I will do the entire beginning
[Applause]
[Music]
all right